another gaming you show it for you
Nintendo of America has just released
some sales stats for the Legend of Zelda
tears of the Kingdom the Tweet says the
Legend of Zelda tears of the kingdom is
sold over 10 million copies worldwide in
its first three days becoming the
fastest selling game in the history of
the Legend of Zelda series they added
thanks to all of those enjoying Link's
latest adventure for context here are
some of the previously fastest selling
games of all time with Grand Theft Auto
5 from 2013 at number one which was 11
million copies in its first 24 hours
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 3 is a
number two with 6.5 million copies in
North America and Europe but Zelda is
only on one platform only on the switch
making this all the more impressive